Britain's Prime Minister has her job on
the line in a critical vote tonight
after her plan to leave the European
Union was thoroughly rejected front page
headlines in London say Theresa May is
fighting for her life and call yes coal
yesterday's parliamentary vote a
historic humiliation Roxana Saberi is in
London with the impact felt around the
world Roxana good morning good morning
the defeat was crushing and worse than
anyone here expected now the government
has just weeks to figure out another way
forward the eyes to the right 202 the
nose to the left
432 the overwhelming defeat of Prime
Minister Theresa Mays brexit deal it is
clear that the house does not support
this deal plunges the United Kingdom
into its deepest political crisis in
living memory every day that passes
without this issue being resolved means
more uncertainty more bitterness and all
rancor May has been negotiating a brexit
deal with the European Union for nearly
two years if she survives a vote of
confidence set for today she'll have to
present an alternate plan by Monday or
asked to delay the deadline with just 72
days until the UK is scheduled to leave
the EU the landslide vote is causing
even more economic uncertainty
especially if the country crashes out of
Europe with no deal at all the UK is the
fourth largest export destination for
American goods and services if there's
no brexit deal a weakened pound would
make us Goods more costly to buy in the
UK the u.s. forming and manufacturing
sectors could be hit hardest with the
biggest exports including aircraft and
machinery as well as wine and beer tree
nuts and live animals Schenker singham
works for the Institute of Economic
Affairs why should Americans care in
terms of their economy if this continues
then we're going to have another
recession we're gonna have another
depression it's going to mean jobs lost
it's going to mean economic opportunity
for gone for Americans for the whole
world the US Chamber of Commerce says
the stakes are high for American
businesses that have invested in the UK
as a way of accessing EU markets some of
those companies have open subsidiaries
elsewhere in Europe to make sure they
can keep doing business as usual fiona
and the stakes are high for the EU which
of course is the USS largest trading
partner so a lot of ramifications coming
out of that Roxana Saberi thank you